over the weekend
failed former president Donald Trump
spent a ton of time on his social media
platform truth essential truth truth
call it whatever you want one of the
topics which Trump addressed was this
spy balloon as it is being called from
China which was popped by Joe Biden and
Donald Trump sending a number of
outrageous truths let's just dig right
into them and see if we can figure out
why is the guy so triggered is it
because of his failing presidential
campaign is it because he wants
attention is it because it's a sort of
if I can't play in the sandbox I'm going
to poop in it so none of the other kids
can play it and either
I don't know Trump truth and quote the
Chinese balloon situation is a disgrace
just like the Afghanistan horror show
and everything else surrounding the
grossly incompetent Biden Administration
now what's funny about that is on on
Afghanistan when Trump was asked what
exactly would you have done differently
than Joe Biden he couldn't articulate
anything he would have done differently
Biden executed the Trump plan and
similarly just like Biden popped the
balloon Trump probably would have popped
the balloon so it's kind of kind of a
weird start Trump continues they are
only good at cheating in elections and
disinformation and now they are putting
out that a balloon was put up by China
during the Trump Administration in order
to take the heat off the slow-moving
Biden fools
China had too much respect for Trump for
this to have happened and it never did
just fake disinformation
well it turns out that that's not true
it turns out that there were Chinese spy
balloons which three times
flew over U.S airspace in U.S airspace
under Trump now in Trump's defense you
all know that there is plenty to slam
Trump about I don't need to make things
up in Trump's defense on this issue the
latest report as of a few hours ago is
that the Trump Administration was not
told about these balloons when they were
uh over in U.S airspace
um that this was learned about after
Biden took office so if that's the case
Trump's just going further Trump's
saying China never would have done it
well China did do it you just didn't
know about it Trump contribute
continuing on Troth Central quote who
sends a billion dollar blimp with the
most sophisticated equipment in the
world and large enough to hold 10 cars
or three large buses into a complex
pattern over the United States without
it quite possibly being manned such as
the manned spacecraft China should have
been called to ask if no shoot it down
if yes negotiate the greatest deal ever
I guess Trump is saying that he believes
that such a balloon likely would have
been manned even though there's no
evidence of that and if so he would have
tried I guess to kidnap the balloon and
its pilot which didn't exist and extort
the Chinese or something I mean this is
a very crazy way to manage Foreign
Relations but after all it is Trump and
then maybe the funniest truth of all
Trump then closing it out with quote the
Chinese would never have floated the
blimp quote balloon over the United
States if I were president and as I
already mentioned to you
Chinese spy balloons did fly in U.S
airspace three times while Donald Trump
was President of the United States as
far as we believe right now Trump wasn't
told about it but China did indeed have
the audacity often they play up well you
know Putin never would have invaded
because he was scared and China never
well China did
China did the thing he says they never
would have done now the third piece to
this Fiasco is what's the wildest
conspiracy theory to come out of it well
let's look at that next one of our
sponsors today is fume fume is on a
mission to accelerate Humanity's breakup
from the bad habits that consume far too
many of us including ones that harm our
health fume is a natural diffusive
device that uses plants and Behavioral
Science to trade out your negative habit
for a positive one fume is not a vape
it's a non-electronic device designed to
transform your negative habits instead
of PODS filled with potentially harmful
chemicals like a vape fume uses cores
infused with plants like peppermint and
cinnamon for delicious natural flavors
fumes new version 2 model is Snappy and
tactile with an adjustable airflow dial
and a magnetic end cap that's fun to
fidget it with its fumes goal to make
switching easy or even enjoyable they
have thousands of five star reviews from
people just like you who have
successfully switched when other
Solutions didn't work head to trifum.com
and use the code Pacman to get 10 off
today when you get the journey pack
which comes with three unique flavors
and the new version to fume the link is
down below